who went in for the first kiss me
i did
he was taking a long time kourtney
kardashian opens up about the moment she
and travis barker went from long-time
friends and neighbors to lovers
he was one of my closest friends for
probably eight years we could just be
ourselves we fell in love and now he's
my boyfriend and turns out court was the
one to make the first move
i was definitely always attracted to
travis
i just think it was the right time in my
life this is her time to shine baby
during the season premiere of hulu's the
kardashians the 42 year old pooch
founder dishes on her relationship with
the blink 182 drummer
the second we
fell in love i think we knew how
different it was from anything
either of us have ever had before and so
i think that you know we absolutely
see a future together
of course trav popped the question back
in october and earlier this month the
lovebirds said i do in an unofficial las
vegas wedding you did a practice run on
the wedding congratulations thank you so
when is the real wedding and what will
that look like because we're really
seeing your love story with your soul
mate on the new show we don't know yet
we're just you know living our best
lives
but before they were kravis they were
besties that is until the pandemic when
the reality star says she made her
feelings known my closest best friends
have always said you have to hook up
with travis we were texting and so
i just put it out there like flirtatious
conversation
good news for court travis was into it
and invited her over for a good
old-fashioned movie night but the two
kept things pg the whole movie he didn't
make a move the movie was over and then
i was like we started another movie and
i was like i don't have time for this
like movie marathon so i made the first
move and the rest as they say is history
[Music]
but no one was really all that surprised
well except for court's momager kris
jenner
this is a relationship that i don't
think anybody saw coming because they've
known each other for so long and they
were such good friends i definitely saw
this coming for years we have been
telling courtney that her and travis
should hook up they are so happy
seem so in love
and never stop making out by the way
like ever
oh we know chris
we know i'm just like living life
living life and trying to have a little
barker travis and i want to have a baby
put the sample in this cup
we'll take our mics off you know get the
audio what has it been like to be on the
path to baby with travis i mean it's a
beautiful thing that we'd love to have
happen um but
you know the journey is a bit hard for
any women who have been on it and
emotional
back in february a source told et that
court and trav are so in love and are
open to the idea of having children
together and growing their family of
course courtney shares three kids with
her ex scott disick twelve-year-old
mason nine-year-old penelope and
seven-year-old reign while travis has
two kids with his ex shayna mugler 18
year old landon and 16 year old alabama
that's one thing that you know travis
and i you know do agree on you know our
children come first and their happiness
and as long as you know the kardashians
are good to my kids you know that's all
that matters to me as a mom and while
the couple continues to try for a baby
one thing's for sure court is one
smitten kitten it's like the first time
that i've seen her happy i'm like so
happy for this win for her because she
really deserves it
[Music]